i ragazzi e per luigi questo video sono
fa vj ed oggi stiamo per tirare un
attestata sui [ __ ] gli stati anche
se non ci chiamava non importa purché
ragazzi siamo sul simulator e cianci ho
messo tipo 40 minuti per sbloccare st
stasta capra capra di classe sì non è un
filmino e una capra di classe ma cosa
bellissima di di questa capra di classe
che cammina in un modo troppo sexy non
ho parole del mio dio
a parte il fatto che corre cioè non è
che corda tu hai il corallo fate
conoscenza mi raccomando ok mai stato
perfetto e la cosa che mi ha sorpreso di
più è che adesso sguardo stupendo cioè
io ragazzi non c'ho parte la smettete di
investirmi cribioli questa roba qui
chiamata capra di classe riesce ad
andare b ho capito che la volevi tu ma
bastava chiedere zio avranno vedere se
riusciva veramente andare in bici stano
eccolo è una cosa un po strana
effettivamente però non importa no no
minchia che freestyler all indietro
proprio cioè di anzi come vuoti ragazzi
immortalarsi tua non si possono fare due
metri senza cosa ci fa questo sulla
fermata
buongiorno io sono una capra di classe
c'era una stanza per me io deve andare
volentieri la mano ma non so se te ne
sei accorta solo un pinguino se ti dava
sentito modo di sopra alimento che cosa
di del mouse che successo dio terminati
ok ragazzi non so perché mi sono
addormentato davanti a una festa la cosa
che cosa ho fatto fregare non ha fatto
un cazzo hanno potuto l'oro ecco come
questo
gente
[Musica]
sì ma non mi ha abbracciato in area
potente io io sono sono qui perché
voglio voglio prendere posso salire qua
sopra normativi se mi serve quello che
serve
grazie mille all'ora che io di solito
prendo l'ascensore ma a volte finisco
così più o meno dipende dai giorni fatta
finire per minacce la cosa bellissima
lista maschera che potete far ballare la
gente in un motivo questo vedete come
depresso io tolgo la vita dolce le temi
come sia possibile ma faccio questo
effetto alla gente yeah yeah
oh oh oh oh yeah io non ho mai visto una
una zona cavalcare un pinguino però va
bene c'è sempre una prima volta regali o
che sono un doping non so come si
trattano le donne del so che ti piace
andare tutte giostra io non so che cosa
farò della mia vita ma prima o poi un
pinguino bisogna cavalcarlo perché è
bellissimo
meglio di così non poteva succedere a
venti ragazzi le gite in famiglia che si
fanno in bici che questo è molto meglio
sembra che io abbia abbia la stessa
complicata nel suo culo e la cosa è
quanto scena regala probabile d'accordo
riga per quanto possa esser inquietante
sta cosa della tizia velo problemi
vedere se riesco a darmi un [ __ ]
caffè ragazzi questo si chiama copra
piumata credo che sia questo il nome
però vorrei capire un attimo dalla fermi
fu un secondo ok la cosa bellissima
comunque ragazzi perché se la faccia
troppo simpatica come ti sei permesso a
lou reed a [ __ ] ragazzi ha provato a
sfidarmi fosse l'ultima cosa che ha
fatto che questi camion però si può fare
due metri senza che qualcuno ti investe
oti calpestino perché non è possibile
no no no non si può entrare si ok corsa
ho fatto di preciso ma il bello ragazzi
che ognuno ha il suo stile nella andare
in bici tipo questo è e lo stile è
venuto fantastico c'è chi non ho parole
ragazzi magari se guardassi la strada
sarebbe anche un po più facile lacrime e
bello che si esalta bola c'è una bici
che vola e stupendo gli ho paura di
scoprire non è che faccia quel questa è
una gara completa la gara se vai gara di
ciclismo coipel nut chiesto tizio prega
chi cazzo ti fermi un attimo c'è un
tizio sulla sulla schiena che non so chi
sia ma voi state
quando miglior ciclista della città rega
non potete farlo c'è una dove girare
vero meraviglioso siamo soltanto finiti
su una panchina mano dentro una panchina
ma non importa
siamo ancora in gara ragazzi siamo
ancora in gara non siamo un cazzo ignara
ragazzi li faccio perché sono partito
malissimo andare a fare competizioni
ciclistiche non me la cavo molto bene
non è possibile
minchia che storto ti sta bene lurido
vai vai vai vai se no non edizione però
grazie grazie grazie
guarda che una cosa incredibile
lou reed abcd mense inutile perfetto ma
quante volte ti investire io per essere
gas
salve che cazzo chi è chi è questo amico
mio non so che cosa stai facendo qui ma
io ti salverò e ti porterò in salvo
giustamente allora senti come se vuoi
stare qua non c'è problema cioè di farmi
un favore mettiti comodo su
qualcos'altro
buongiorno arkia lei io non ho idea di
che cosa diavolo stia succedendo st
episodio proposito sta succedendo di
tutto
trovo gente che si siede non si sa cosa
fa vabbè è per gente che mi cadde
addosso a me io non ho parole ragazzi
fate andare vedono un attimino tizia
eccolo qui perfetto l'ultima volta l'ho
visto in mano visto malissimo
non ho ancora capito chi è sto titolo è
l'ultimo episodio mia mi ha fatto
parecchia paura ma non lo so ancora se
toni mi preme sapere perché sto tizio
sta piange allora la smetti che mi sta
dando fastidio continuerò non capire chi
è ma non me ne frega niente io mi tuffo
minchia non c'era l'acqua era era troppo
bassa ok lo inquina satana con doppio
salto e jeffe chi non so che cosa fosse
fuori però sono volevo vederla questa
cioè non giorno quest'acqua estate pop e
della prescindere una cosa stupenda è
bellissima e bellissimo poiché di posta
ancora l'altro non ho visto che cosa c'è
qua dentro perché senti io però tu non
puoi star bene tutto il giorno qui a
bere e guardare la piscina mentre io mi
faccio un culo che non ha idea allora
adesso ci beviamo o questo insieme no
perfetto per i che l'alcol uccide dopo
un po sta affogando ci sarò d'amico mia
forza forza respira respirano aver
aspettato segnano pazzini non lo fa
ok perfetto ci siamo perché sta
affogando mi dispiace devo fare devo
intervenire con la respirazione bocca a
bocca
con una capra che per te la senti la
lingua la senti torna nel mondo reale
torna tra noi forza amico mio by così
che ce la fai vai così non ce la
possiamo fare
l'abbiamo perso el'ato amico perciò se
bellissimo fai qualcosa che forse
qualcuno deve seppellire pure te ma non
importa che vogliono ho capito perché
sta sparando bolle ragazzi cioè vabbè ma
proviamo anche questa perché ancora non
l'ho più cos'è sta a qualche vado senza
bici proprio c'è una è una gara senza
bici ok questa mi sembra alquanto più
semplice dove cazzo sta altro punto ho
già sbagliato importanza non importa
dove devo andare di qua c'è ma non c'è
non ci sono indicazioni dove devo andare
vabbè non importa cioè una cosa
infattibile cosa che ho dovuto mandare
di preciso mi fa andare di soprano a e
[ __ ] sì ma che cosa ne posso
sapere io c'è chi lo aveva visto sta
roba
fatemi capire di qua di qua devo dico
minchia corso presto cosa ho fretta
ho preso preso il camion effetti ho
preso anche il camion ha preso anche
quel sì no no no la strada sbagliata la
strada sbagliata che qual lo sa per
certo pure lei marciapiede ma com'è che
io quando tentò di fare una gara
succedono le cose più impensabili amica
mi hai mangiato qualcosa di marcio
ultimamente in vita snella proprio è le
gare sono due siamo due cose che non ci
hanno un cazzo che c'azzeccano insieme
ma proprio zero vediamo di capirci un
secondo devo andare qua sopra
ma come cazzo ha fatto a non vederlo
prima ma spiegatemelo ok ok perfetto va
bene va bene ok allora questa un po
difficile
non ce l'hai fatta non chiedetemi come
nicchia se passa qualcosa mi incazzo ok
come ci arrivo la cera e io che ero
andato 6 fuochi d'artificio come
deficiente che non posso sapere noi vedo
che ci sono le frecce che mi indica ok
ok se in chiave l'ho preso
non chiedetemi come eccolo lì fantastico
ce la sto facendo miracolosamente mezzo
ai rifiuti
sembra facile ragazzi sono passati così
ma non è facile per niente bene cosa ok
ok perfetto di qua ok meraviglioso già
sto facendo non so come c'è un tizio che
corre lì sopra non fatemi non facciamoci
domande mai che buona vai che buona
vecchia buona vecchia buona sono già
messi sta tizia sopra sarei anche più
veloce ma non importa
di qua perfetto do passare in mezzo in
mezzo ad ora in mezzo al buco perché
siamo troppo però amico io allora già
fatto un tempo di merda ti va di
togliersi dalle palle grazie al piano
piano se ce l'ho fatta
un risultato di merda nei peggiori modi
possibili ma va bene così direi che
posso concludere che i ragazzi perché ci
sono questi belli addormentati mi fanno
troppa pena quindi regala subito servito
vi è piaciuto mi dispiace se sto
leccando le poppe della tua donna però
non incassare
come non detto cosa sarebbe ragazzi 6
video è piaciuto la sua compimento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook con
ogni video tratta nella dedizione sarà
salveresti discrimini ci rivediamo il
prossimo video belle ragazze